well had we not participated in the
American War you know after 9/11 we
would not have been the world's
dangerous country by participating in
the war and I repeat I was against it
because you see here in 80s we were
training these Mujahideen people to do a
job against the Soviet when they
occupied Afghanistan so these people
were trained by Pakistan funded by the
American CIA and now a decade later when
the Americans come into Afghanistan the
same groups were all in Pakistan are
supposed to say that no not because the
Americans are there it's no longer jihad
it's terrorism you know it was a big
contradiction and I strongly felt that
you know Pakistan should have been
neutral because by joining in these
groups turned against us so we you know
we lost 70,000 people we lost you know
as I said over a hundred billion dollars
to the economy and in the end we were
blamed for the for the the Americans
don't see succeeding in Afghanistan I
felt was very unfair on Pakistan